hello everyone
welcome
i'm stephen pitty professor of history
uh here at yale and director of yale's
center for the study of race indigeneity
and transnational migration
i'm delighted to see you all
on behalf of my colleagues in the yale
program for the study of anti-semitism
especially my friend maury samuels who
did so much to organize this event i
want to welcome you to what should be a
wonderful discussion with eric k ward
that's entitled skin in the game
anti-semitism white nationalism and the
work for an inclusive democracy
let me also thank inessa laskova for her
hard work on putting this event together
thank you so much younessa
so we have roughly an hour here today
together uh let me encourage everyone
present to consider putting your
questions that you have for mr ward into
the zoom q a and i'll do my best to read
as many of them as i can aloud to mr
ward at the conclusion of his remarks so
p please keep that in mind
eric k ward
a nationally recognized expert on the
relationship between authoritarian
movements hate violence and preserving
inclusive inclusive democracy
is the recipient of the 2021 civil
courage prize the first american to win
that award in its 21-year history
in his more than 30-year civil rights
career
eric's worked with community groups
government and business leaders human
rights advocates and philanthropy as an
organizer director program officer
consultant and board member
eric's widely quoted writings and
speeches are credited with key narrative
shifts in recent decades
he currently serves as executive
director of western state center
as senior fellow with the southern
poverty law center and race forward and
as co-chair for the proteus fund
eric thank you so much for being with us
today we're really excited to have you
touch
it is such a pleasure to to be with you
today
i'm delighted to have this opportunity
to to speak with everyone
of course the question of anti-semitism
white nationalism and the threat on
democracy
in the front of most americans minds
whether we are
watching the the beginning days of a
civil trial in charlottesville
where
victims of neo-nazi violence from the
unite the right riot
are seeking to hold accountable uh the
perpetrators
whether we're looking at the recent
arrests and charges of an individual
who set fire to to a synagogue
or
uh
watching with great interest how the
federal government will proceed and its
prosecution and investigation of the
january six insurrection
the the stress on democracy is very real
the rise of hate violence
the increasing number of americans who
believe that
political violence
is the solution to our country's uh
problems
and the answer to the question of who is
an american what will america look like
are very real
this journey started for me
back in
the late 80s
i had
moved to eugene oregon
in 1986 and
i was part of the
punk movement
in southern california at the time
was the lead singer of a band a garage
punk band spa ban
that went on to be known uh as sublime
but as we were attending shows this kind
of diverse creative set of folks who
found each other
and a new identity through music we
began to notice some of the pressure
that was happening within the music
scene within the hardcore punk scenes
individuals were showing up
in increasing numbers who were calling
themselves
white power punks and eventually calling
themselves neo-nazi skinheads
and they were very intent on both
policing and criminalizing those who
they felt didn't belong
within those communities
eventually i moved up to
eugene oregon in 1986.
when i moved up right before me another
individual i moved up from southern
california
he was older than me he was retired his
name was richard butler and uh richard
butler was a uh retired aircraft
mechanic former world war ii vet
and uh recently retired from hugh's
aircraft he
relocated to the northwest not oregon
but to a place called idaho a town
called
hayden lake and he's restarted his
church
jerusalem church of jesus christ
christian aryan nations
the alien nations taught three things
the first was that jews were the literal
children of satan
the second was that
people of color
were referred to as sub-human
chattel
meaning
humans without souls
and the third was that the enemy nations
and richard butler taught
that the united states was to be a new
aryan homeland and that the pacific
northwest would be the beginnings of
that
uh uh
white uh revolution
it is in that period that i first came
to understand
that racism wasn't merely a set of
behaviors that it was also a social
movement phenomenon
eventually i came to understand that
what i was looking at
were the
emergence of a movement we now know to
be white nationalism
i was a young activist then and i think
it's important to say this was before
the internet
and as we joined together with others to
try to manage this violence and
organizing we collected flyers those
flyers were often warnings of further
violence or harassment
this was a period of great upheaval by
the white nationalist movement
uh in the pacific northwest
they believed that the pacific northwest
was the beginnings of that homeland and
they engaged in acts of violence
including the assassination of a radio
talk show host by the name of alan burr
in denver colorado
the murder beating death of an ethiopian
student
by the name of mulligan sarah who was
attacked on his way home one night from
school and beaten to death
with baseball back
by uh neo-nazi skinheads these were just
a few of the incidences that that
occurred here in the pacific northwest
in truth much of what the nation faces
now was first experienced nearly three
decades ago
here in the pacific northwest at the
time it was hard to get the nation's
attention and in fact until
charlottesville it was very hard to get
the nation's attention focused
on the fact that racism was not only
systemic
but a social movement phenomenon and
that those social movements actually
pivoted right our understanding of what
was acceptable in society
but these were the movements we were
monitoring and as we were collecting
those flyers i was telling you about
we began to notice something and those
who had done this work before us began
to point this out
that all the flyers no matter how
vertically racist anti-black or
anti-latino or no matter how anti-muslim
or homophobic or anti-immigrant
there was always some anti-semitic
caricature
of a jewish figure or symbol on these
flyers it didn't matter whether they
were attacking
those who had been diagnosed with hiv
aids it didn't matter whether they're
going after immigrants or the media
right or
african-americans or latinos or women
there was always this character
and it is when we began to understand uh
one simple truth
which was anti-semitism wasn't simply at
the core of this white nationalist
movement
right that it was the core of white
nationalism
and that it was so central to white
nationalism
that i as a anti-racist racial justice
activist right seeking black liberation
quickly came to understand
that we and other marginalized groups
would never achieve opportunity and
equity if we were not also active in the
struggle to uproot this form of
anti-jewish hate
amongst 21st century white nationalists
right jews were being cast in the same
role that they had always filled for
anti-semites as the absolute others
demons stirring a pot of lesser evils
and the driving force behind white
dispossession
as i wrote in skin in the game outlining
the white nationalist worldview
at the foundation of that movement was
an explicit claim that jews were a
separate race
this is really critical for us to hold
what i'm trying to to unearth here and
lift up
is that for the white nationalist
movement right their hatred of jews was
not a religious form of bigotry
jews weren't passed as a religion
but as a separate race
right and it filled the same role right
that has always been filled up by
anti-semites right placing jews as the
absolute other right demon stirring a
pot of lesser evils right the driving
force behind white dispossession
it was an explicit claim that jews were
a separate race
that they weren't white
and that their ostensible position as
white was merely a trick right the
greatest trick that the devil ever
played in the words of the time of a
leading white nationalist figure by the
name of pete peters who was a
counterpart of richard butler and his
aryan nations
right
for pete peters and the white
nationalist movement jews despite and
indeed because of the fact that they
were seen as white
were placed as an enemy race that must
be exposed and eliminated
it is often why i tell people that
anti-semitism is core to white
nationalist ideology it is central it is
their world view
it is that fantasy
of invisible jewish power
that explains for white nationalists how
black americans a race of supposed
inferiors right could orchestrate the
end of jim crow
or how feminists in the lgbtq community
could up in traditional gender roles
or even how immigrant workers in this
country could mount a challenge right
successful challenge to economic
inequality
folks often asked me over these last 30
years right it was 30 years ago that i
attended my first white nationalist
meeting right to monitor that meeting
the reason i attended
was that uh
at the time again we couldn't google
things we had to go sit in meetings we
had to read
uh their writings and listen to their
talks and i simply wasn't going to ask
people to do something i hadn't done
myself
so i walked into many of these meetings
now these weren't the hardcore neo-nazi
meetings these were the coalitional
meetings that looked much like the
alt-right today
white nationalists
tax resistors uh a paramilitary figures
and others who are building right the
first vestiges of what we now know to be
the alt-right
how was i accepted in these meetings
well the truth is is i was accepted
because these groupings right
saw jews as their primary
not black people not other people of
color
certainly we were challenges and we were
troubled
but we were placed
right as the puppets of our jewish
puppet masters
they were willing to place me in the
role of a potential ally
in the words of one leading
white nationalist figure at the time
lewis bean
he called for a new
multi-racialism within the white
nationalist movement at least a
multi-racial coalition
in the words of one of his counterparts
in a meeting in estes parks colorado
leading
up to oklahoma city
one of his counterparts announced first
we deal with the federal government
then we deal with the question of the
jews that is why a multi-racial
coalition
right against the government is called
for in the words of white nationals
folks often ask me
where is the anti-semitism in the white
nationalism
my response is it's everywhere when the
tree of life shooter right said jews
were
committing a genocide against white
people he was using language that was
italy familiar to his fellow white
nationalists
it is such anti-rabid anti-semitism that
is the framework in which this entire
movement functions
but let's be clear about something
white nationalists don't bring
anti-semitism to our communities
they merely organize the bigotry that
already exists
it is often why i say as an anti-racist
activist
one of the things that is fundamental to
my beliefs
is that to refuse to deal with any
ideology of domination is to abet it
fighting anti-semitism cuts off the
animating force of white nationalism for
the sake of all marginalized communities
in this moment right
we in this country are dealing with two
significant phenomena
the persistent and historic nature and
impact of white supremacy
a system grounded on white superiority
the belief
that skin color
dictates one's place and value in
society
it is made up right on an eye on the
false notion that race is a real
biological definition which it is not
what we understand is that white
supremacy in the concept of race is a
social construct
largely created in order right to
establish social control in our society
it is what allowed the quick and fast
development
of the united states into a global
economic powerhouse
white supremacy was grounded upon three
specific principles
the first was the stolen resources and
land of native people
the second was a system of shadow
slavery that was like un un none other
right that stripped black people of
their language their culture their
religions right their very relationships
and reconstructed them into black
americans it was those hundreds of years
of free labor in this country that
positioned the united states as the
economic power it is today
but beyond
the stolen resources and genocide of
native people beyond chattel slavery
there was a third pillar in the
construction of white supremacy
and that was the control of women and
sexuality
in society these were three
critical pillars of white supremacy
then along comes this 1960 civil rights
movement
and this 1960 civil rights movement
overthrows white supremacy as the rule
of law and i want to be clear about
something
i'm not saying that white supremacy no
longer exists in america
i can attest as an african-american male
that it exists very much in our society
what i'm saying is that previous to the
victories of the civil rights movement
white supremacy was the uncontested lens
upon which most of us
understood society whether we were
talking about culture politics economics
then
the civil rights movement wins
it creates other lenses pluralism
racial justice
lenses of equity
right
and
it is in that moment that those who were
conditioned to see themselves as
superior because of their skin tone
were thrown into an existential crisis
how could they explain that they lost to
those they saw as inferior
that was impossible
to acknowledge that they lost that moral
fight would be to acknowledge the agency
and humanity of black people
and that simply wasn't going to happen
not because people were bad
but because they had been conditioned in
every way to see black people as
inferior
so they constructed an answer to this
loss
the construction borrowed from the
protocols of the learned elders of zion
a fictional uh anti-semitic account from
europe in the early 1900s that was
spread
by russian secret police who were afraid
of the spread of democracy in europe
particularly in places like germany and
france
this false narrative steeped in
anti-semitic tropes purported to tell a
story
of jewish elders who gathered at
midnight in a cemetery to plot to take
over the world
to the control of the economy culture
finance etc
now we should be clear
this narrative
was a strong narrative
because it understood that
fear and xenophobia towards jews already
existed in society
as i said
white nationalists don't bring
anti-semitism to our communities
they merely organize the anti-semitism
that already exists
good organizers don't try to inject new
ideas in order to galvanize communities
they merely try to tap into the ideas
that already exist in a community so too
was it in the early days of the protocol
but it also was a strong narrative
how strong of a narrative were the
learned were the protocols that learned
elders of zion
well we are bombarded with that
narrative constantly in unconscious ways
not because people understand the
original narrative but because that is
how influential i believe it has been in
the society
i'll give you an example
you don't have to read the protocols to
actually understand the protocols
i often ask people if they've ever heard
of a tv show from the 1990s and early
2000s called the x-files produced and
directed by chris carter
it is a story of two fbi agents who
stumble upon a global conspiracy
a conspiracy
to infect the body politic
through the injection of an alien virus
that aliens have made an appearance
they're hiding among humans
and are slowly corrupting our leaders
and taking control of culture and
finance in order to prepare for this
invasion
and it's merely two fbi agents who have
discovered the truth and no one believes
them and their job is to wake up the
rest of the world to this conspiracy
if you've ever seen the x-files or many
alien invasion stories
you too
actually already understand
the ground narrative of the protocols
that learn to elders of zion
now i have to give a disclaimer here i'm
not here to say chris carter is
anti-semitic but even that the x-files
are anti-semitic
what i'm trying to help people
understand
is that anti-semitism functions on a
spectrum
from the conscious to the unconscious
level
if anti-semitism continues to spread
in the united states if the white
nationalist movement taps into it
effectively
it is because it is already existent
it's often why i say there is no left or
right
or conservative or liberal anti-semitism
there's merely anti-semitism in society
and how we tap into it to build power
and this is my next point
we should understand
the white nationalist movement isn't
spreading anti-semitism or even other
forms of bigotry in order to spread
bigotry
they're merely organizing the bigotry to
build political power
to reshape the society into what well
let me explain
i talked about white supremacy earlier a
historic and present day system of
inequality discrimination and
exploitation
one that still exists right in the de
facto state and was once the solo rule
of law in this country successfully
turned back by the civil rights movement
in the 1960s as i explained
i talked about how those who believed in
jim crow and separate but equal
right could not accept that they lost to
black people because they've been
conditioned to see themselves as
inferior
right to are superior to black people
but the protocols became a very
convenient answer
for them they could state
that they didn't lose to black people
because as we said in their eyes that
was impossible
instead they lost to this global jewish
conspiracy
if white supremacy the system of
exploitation was built upon the paper of
anti-blackness and the genocide of
native people
white nationalism was written upon the
paper of anti-semitism
it's often why i say to people that we
must not conflate the two terms
when we conflate a system with a social
movement
it confuses us in the tools that are
needed to respond effectively to each
phenomenon
i often liken comparing or conflating
the two
to comparing a cow in a big map
now look both a cow and a big mac are
made out of beef
but when one drops their big mac on the
ground you don't call a veterinarian
when we conflate systems
with social movements we can fuel we
confuse the necessary tools needed to
address both
but there's also another danger
that we get into debates around higher
which one has more effect
well the truth is that both are
undercutting democracy in the society
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
through its defeat of white supremacy
under the rule of law
brought democracy into full life in the
united states
now not complete life so please don't be
a literalist with me
let's understand both social movements
and conditions in society
unfold and flow along arcs on time
what i mean right is that we understand
in the words of john lewis
that before the 1960 civil rights
movement
democracy was merely an aspiration
the advent and success of the civil
rights movement of the 1960s
evolved democracy from an aspiration to
reality
the role of our generation is to secure
and continue to advance that reality
but there is now a backlash
for you see the white nationalist
movement isn't best thought of as a
revolutionary movement
it actually is best thought of as a as a
backlash a backlash against the
victories of the 1960 civil rights
movement
a movement that has slowly been growing
right for the last four decades in this
country
a movement that has been growing without
much response
see social movements don't appear out of
thin air
you know that 1960 civil rights movement
i keep referencing
well if you talk to actual historians
you may be listening on this
they will tell you without a doubt the
1960 civil rights movement didn't start
in the 1960s
in fact most of the major victories of
the civil rights movement occurred in
the mid 1950s
rosa parks
little rock brown versus board of
education to name a few
but even as you talk to these academics
who are well versed on the history of
the civil rights movement they will tell
you something else
that that 1960 civil rights movement
didn't get underway in the 1950s but in
the 1930s and 40s social movements grow
and influence over time
and the mistake we have made as racial
justice and human rights activists in
this country
is that we have assumed that we are the
only social movements on the game board
of democracy that we are the only social
movements that matter
our own arrogance has left our
communities and the 75 years of
sacrifice of those who came for us
vulnerable in this moment
you see the white nationalist movement
understands one thing
that a pluralist democracy is its worst
nightmare
that is successful democracy that
functions right
that is people centered accountable
right and and uh transparent
undermines the white nationalist fear
and existential crisis
right
and what we have to understand moving
forward
is that we need to reevaluate the
importance of democracy
i understand the citizen i'm a black man
in america
i understand the rage of mistreatment
and the incompleteness of democracy
and how it has been used to protect
inequality both here in the united
states and abroad
but we also have to understand that the
democracy right that those who came
before us sacrificed died and struggled
to build
has brought more to this country to
marginalized communities and white folks
than any other ideology to date
we should understand that democracy
inclusive democracy participatory
democracy
that makes real this republic
is one of the most radical ideologies
ever in existence
white nationalists don't like it because
the truth is is that the democracy
that
these civil rights activists built
has delivered more for white america
than white supremacy and the white
nationalist movement ever can and ever
will
democracy for the white nationalist
movement is a threat
because it makes a lie of their argument
that race war is inevitable in this
country
[Music]
but we should understand
if we want to know the real threat
towards democracy
it isn't the white nationalist movement
we have to be brave enough to pick up
the mirror and to take a look in it
i reflect on a rally that took place
four or five years ago now
it took place here in portland oregon it
was an alt-right protest
so counter-protesters showed up
and so did others
at one point as i was monitoring this
rally
i'm trying to understand what the level
of mobilization was in the city
i noticed an alt-right activist sitting
down
there was a guy with a camera who had it
shoved in his face and screaming at him
and demanding that this alt-right white
nationalist activist explain why he was
here in portland
didn't he know the city of portland
didn't want him
didn't he know counter protesters didn't
want him didn't he know the mayor of
portland didn't want him here in the
city and why was he here the cameraman
demanded an answer
what this white nationalist activist
said
is worthy of us paying attention to
he looked at the guy and he said i've
heard we're not wanted here but the
truth is
is that portland he said is a shrinking
black population
by both percentage and whole number
it's a true fact
he then went on to say you can say you
don't want us here
but you're doing something we could
never get away with
you were actually disappearing the black
people of portland oregon
that was his response
in short he was calling us hypocrites
you see
each day that we allow systemic
inequality to exist in our society
we further mark ourselves as the
hypocrites of a pluralistic
multicultural multiracial democracy
when we leave unchecked the issues of
segregation and housing
in employment
in education
in health
we do the work of white nationalism
we help lift it up as the alternative
we are in a moment of great populism in
this country
very few people are interested in the
status quo
why
the status quo has not benefited the
majority of americans whether they are
people of color or white
people want and demand
new ways of walking through society
[Music]
the answer that the status quo is
sufficient
is not a sufficient answer
instead we have to make real the promise
of a multi-racial democracy
one that people can practice and taste
each and every day
if we don't do this
let's be clear
people will increasingly
choose the vision of white nationalism
why it's one that everyone understands
when i say the words
make america great again
you don't have to ask me what that looks
like what that sounds like what that
feels like
we see it each and every day
and we knew it even before the words
were uttered
but when we say inclusive democracy
when we say a pluralist society
we have not set visions of what that
looks like
we
have to understand
people will pick the future that they
know even if it is unhealthy for them
over the unknown nearly every time
it's important that we continue to move
forward
to make our society responsive and to
bring opportunity to all americans
but the white nationalist movement
understands something else too
that anti-semitism isn't just an attack
on the jewish community
it is a way of undermining belief in
democracy
by providing a conspiratorial worldview
that provides very simple answers
and allows us to put our fears onto a
small community the jewish community
but it's not just in that way
we should understand as people of color
immigrants and women
that anti-semitism is much of a physical
threat to us as it is the jewish
community
whether we are talking about attacks the
mass shootings in el paso targeting
latinos at a walmart
or the targeting of sikhs in wisconsin
or the targeting of african-american
churchgoers in charlotte south carolina
or the targeting of jews
in pittsburgh
in each case the killer believed
that they were engaging in an
existential war with the jewish
community
that's because anti-semitism as i said
before is not merely a set of behaviors
but an ideology in a world view
i think
i am not exaggerating to argue that most
mission oriented hate crimes in the
united states
were largely driven by anti-semitism
regardless of who the actual victims
were
so those of us who are non-jewish have
to understand that we are as much at
risk to anti-semitism
as the jewish community is and the
democracy
that we have struggled to build
so how do we move forward
first of all
we need large
vibrant
national debates on anti-semitism
it means leaning into courageous
conversations
until we as a society start naming
anti-semitism and the anti-semitic
tropes
we will continue to play them out as
unconscious bias both individually as
and as a society
because anti-semitism denies the agency
of marginalized communities with
legitimate grievances
anti-semitism becomes a convenient
excuse
by those who seek to backlash and to
clap down on the push for racial justice
in this country
and finally
anti-semitism provides simple answers
to the complex and nuanced conversations
we need to be having
understanding anti-semitism helps
protect you from the dog whistle
politics that are in play
when we hear terms like globalist or
eastern establishment or even the media
being bandied about
those who are well-versed in the tropes
of anti-semitism
understand many of the conversations
that are happening right at a conscious
level but let's be clear
at the unconscious level all of us are
being impacted by these anti-semitic
narratives
so we move forward and open up the space
for discussions on anti-semitism that
means not being so quick to treat
everyone as if they are david duke or
louis farrakhan
it means understanding right that as we
learn and practice anti-semitism we are
likely to stumble and make mistakes
but if we unfairly pure you know
penalize people
because of their mistakes
we will shut down the very conversations
we need to have in this moment
as i've said as a racial justice
activist
one cannot fight racism in this country
without being willing to experience it
none can fight anti-semitism another
form of racism in this country without
being willing to experience it
it is the unfair birth
of moving towards a more equitable
society
lastly i want to say this
we have to understand the moment we are
in right now
we live in a country right now where
synagogues are being attacked they are
not alone
we are in a society where they are being
set on fire
the jews are being attacked on the
streets of the united states
the anti-defamation league the
department of homeland security the fbi
have documented record
numbers of anti-semitic crimes being
reported over the last two years
increasingly so
we have to recognize the moment we are
in
we cannot fight anti we cannot fight
racism in this country without also
tackling anti-semitism
and we can't tackle anti-semitism
without tackling racism
if the injury and the assault on 140 law
enforcement officers
on the capitol steps of this of
washington dc with little fanfare or
reaction
does not recognize uh does not tell you
what moment we're in right now
i fear nothing i'm going to say in the
question question and answer period
will convince you
but i will leave you with this last
final word
your role in this moment
when i was a kid
you grew up very poor
and by summer
most i and my other friends were out of
resources
and you usually find us sitting outside
of the apartment building on the lawn
every summer we would remember this game
we played called if i were
and we'd sit in a circle and if i were
went if i were driving down the middle
of a freeway and the brakes went out
here's how i would respond
and we'd argue about how we'd respond or
how we would what would we do in that
moment
if i found myself in the lion's cage how
that would happen and the lion came out
here's what i would do
but you know what question we would
always say every summer
if i were in the midst of the 1960s
civil rights movement
here's what i would do and boy would we
argue about what we would or wouldn't do
we didn't understand the choiceless
choices of our parents
we didn't understand what it meant to
grow up under jim crow
separate but equal
the hardcore racism of the 1950s
so we were full of bravado about what we
would or what you do
that question has always haunted me
what would i do in the midst of the
1960s civil rights movement
you may have played similar games with
similar moments in history
what would you have done
well it occurred to me
about five years ago
that i actually no longer needed to ask
that question
and neither do any of you
the truth is this
whatever it is we would have done
in the midst of the 1960s
is the same thing we're going to do when
we leave this talk today
make it count
many people have sacrificed to bring us
to this very moment
right the gateway to a multi-racial
democracy
it won't come easy
there's no 30-minute sitcom everything
gets tied up nice
this calls for real work and commitment
to save democracy you first have to love
democracy
to save the united states of america
you first have to love the people in the
united states of america
that's what this moment calls for
courage
leaning in
at a time of great complexity
understanding what is it that you will
do
for the 21st century civil rights
movement
make it count
history will judge you
and what you do in this moment matters
thank you and let's take some questions
and comments
thank you so much eric
really appreciate your hard work here
and
always we do have a number of questions
that have come in so i'm going to do my
best to
to send them your way verbally
and i would just remind our
guests in the audience to please
continue to submit questions via the via
the q a
if they have any for you
um one question that's come in asks you
to talk a little bit more about dog
whistling
and uh you noted terms like globalist or
the media that have become important
stand-ins and dog whistles
for anti-semitism and i think the
question asked in particular how you
think this persistence of dog whistling
or perhaps the new forms of dog
whistling
might change how people think in the
university how they how we think about
education how we think about the work
that educators and students are doing uh
in 2021 2022. any thoughts
great question
look i i think we see a number within
the area of anti-semitism
we see a number of dog whistles that are
often put into play right
the idea that somehow the jewish
community
exerts more power and control in a
society right
in society we see that in rhetoric uh
across the political spectrum i i just
think uh uh last week or the week before
uh former uh president uh mr trump
right uh made a statement about how
israel right controls uh
uh the united states and policies of the
united states now he said it as a as a
philosophic statement right seemingly
positive right like when people say
black people are so articulate or dance
so well right these seem like positive
comments but we understand right that
they are merely reinforcing
racist tropes so we see this often this
idea of invisible jewish power that is a
significant trope the other is blood
libel the idea that somehow jews are
sacrificing uh children or or the
vulnerable in a society with with no
care these are the two predominant
tropes but there are a number of
historic tropes i should say right for
those who study anti-semitism
and who are far better experts than i uh
i think it's important to note right
that we all understand that these tropes
predate the origins of anti-semitism
right anti-semitism is a specific form
of anti-jewish bigotry and it is an
ideology but these tropes are very
active in modern anti-semitism and it's
why we need to understand them i think
uh uh
getting checking out out of the library
right or getting a book
by a good academic who
looks through the protocols of the
learned elders of zion right is a good
place to start most of the tropes are
existent in there and if we understand
the trolls
we can then recognize them when they're
in play
and we can point them out
but we have uh for me i understand by
way of example then we'll go to the next
question
if someone starts talking about thugs
right
uh uh i have an idea to start paying a
little bit more attention to what
they're saying
because i understand right the thug is
often a a dog whistle
right uh towards blacks and latinos in
the same way we have to become literate
in the language of of anti-semitism
until we do
all of us will be manipulated about uh
by it no matter where we sit on the
political spectrum
thank you very much uh the questions are
coming in fast and furious um
we have a question here um that asks
about how
white nationalists and and what this
person calls white ring wing populists
um do invoke the discourse of civil
rights when discussing the supposed
dispossession of white people or the
supposed silence of conservatives can
you talk a little bit about this and
whether you see it as a cynical ploy
or in some other way
look we we understand uh from the
inception right anti-semitism the
narrative anti-semitism
paints a picture that jews are seeking
to destroy
european christian
in the united states right race became
much more of a primary identifier
than religion so instead of uh european
destruction of european cushing right it
became the destruction of white
christendom here in the us that is how
anti-semitism is largely defined
we should understand that that continues
to mainstream itself right it
mainstreamed itself from the term uh
white genocide to the id to the chants
and streets of charlottesville
jews will not replace us right to tucker
carlson uh promoting uh the replacement
theory which is just a retelling
right of of the protocols uh uh through
anti-semitic tropes
at the end of the day
demographics are changing in the united
states right uh we are a diverse society
going through a significant demographic
change
that creates demographic anxiety
anxiety right to demographic change is
actually natural
we who are on i put myself on the
progressive left that's where i sit on
the political spectrum this applies
across the political spectrum
we do a terrible job of managing
demographic anxiety we actually tell
people right that uh that anxiety is
unnatural right or or it's bigoted but
the truth is is all of us experience
demographic anxiety we experience
anytime we walk into a room of people we
don't know
all those feelings you're feeling our
demographic anxiety
we need to stop treating people right as
if they are david duke because they are
feeling the change of a society
on the other hand though
white nationalists are exploiting that
demographic anxiety they are telling
those who are experiencing it that it's
not natural right it's not natural to
feel that anxiety
that it's an existential crisis
and that they need to prepare to defend
themselves against that existential
crisis by arming themselves and
preparing for a race war
we should understand that in the midst
of great change on in a society under
stress
covet economic instability right
political violence climate change
that people will begin to believe that
unless we put forward real policies
right that desegregate this society it
is why segregation
and racial profiling are the most
significant national security threats in
this country today
what we understand about demographic
anxiety is that it can be managed
it doesn't go away
right but one learns by putting
themselves in unfamiliar environments
over and over again
when you uh are afraid when you have
anxiety around flying right uh
counselors don't tell you to stop flying
right what they tell you to start flying
more right that there's a way to kind of
manage that anxiety
so we have to get better in terms of
public policy
in understanding that the current
inequality in this society
is killing american democracy there is
no bigger threat and in terms of the
management of the white nationalism
it is racial profiling that is the
largest national security threat
for months right law enforcement in dc
understood that white nationalists were
coming to that community to in an
attempt to disrupt the electoral process
of the united states
yet on that day
we saw them
not in
population you know uh uh uh crowd
control right uh we saw them in very
passive stance
why
because the folks who were marching on
that day weren't black or latino right
they didn't see them as a threat and as
a result they allowed 140 right of their
fellow officers to be injured and five
people were killed
that is that kind of racial profiling
that unconscious bias that is leaving
the rest of us at risk so these are the
issues we have to contend with in this
moment demographic change is real that
will continue to happen
how do we manage demographic anxiety and
how do we get our policies to deal
the underlying segregation that
exasperates that anxiety in our society
thank you we have several questions that
i think are essentially asking about uh
white nationalist leadership and i think
there may be a way in which some people
here may have heard you focusing on a
sort of white nationalist leadership
that might have
been somehow more community based
more working class and so several of
these questions are asking if how you
think about the importance of wealthy
donors the koch brothers as mentioned
and mentioned in one one question um and
other forms of leadership including
people who are actually quite
enfranchised in society and might be
pretending to speak about those who are
not but about whom that could not be
said uh applies to yeah
yeah um i think often we project things
onto uh uh right-leaning movements that
we would never accept for our own
movements on the left right
we would never say
uh that our movements are controlled uh
uh by rich philanthropist because we
receive foundation grants uh we would
never uh uh uh suggest
right that we are being manipulated uh
uh by political elites uh uh above us we
treat our opposition with a level of
arrogance uh
that is astounding to me uh and doesn't
speak to the real issues the truth is is
this
the white nationalist movement is
putting out an effective message
and those who say that they're trying to
create alternatives have failed to do so
right now there are lots of challenges
and there's lots of reasons why on why
the white nationalist movement has more
wind in its sails it's not just a
failure of an alternative
but our ability to get serious about
this moment
and understand that this is not a
question right now of economic
inequality it doesn't mean that economic
inequality isn't an issue that this is
an issue of governance right who gets to
belong in society
is the key question that the other side
is debating right now and it is not just
top down that is grassroots up
we see it i often talk about this and
this may be what people may be speaking
to i refer to a
professor by the name of james aho
university of idaho
in the uh early 2000's and i think
perhaps even until today he's one of the
few uh uh individuals who has done a
substantial look
uh at the white nationalist movement
he's a sociologist he published his
findings in a book called the politics
of righteousness
christian patriotism in idaho so look at
the white nationalist movement in idaho
and he finds some interesting things he
finds for instance
that the white nationalist movement in
idaho has a higher level of income than
the general population of idaho as a
whole right that it is
more highly educated than the general
population of idaho as a whole right
that is not uh unique when we look at uh
authoritarian movements outside the u.s
we see that same trend
right we should not think that because
uh uh
there are more working class or working
poor people in these movements
right that these are working poor
working-class movements that just has to
do with the demographics of the united
states there just happens to be
more working-class and working poor
people to draw from the truth is that
these movements are disproportionately
right uh uh made up of uh upper middle
class uh individuals but but right
they're not manipulating people who are
working class and working poor it's that
working poor working class folks are
choosing one of the few alternatives
that are being presented to them look we
haven't done a good job on the racial
justice side right we have not sent the
message right that white people are also
part of our formula right our way
forward and uh uh until we do a better
job of that right uh people in the midst
of anxiety are going to cling to
whatever they believe
makes them more stable and in a racist
society right a society with unconscious
bias it is going to be the movement with
bias
that wins out in that race unless we
come up with better more broader uh
visions of what we mean when we say
america and americans so
i would just say at the end of the day
uh yes these movements are being funded
through lots of diverse sets of sources
uh uh but i wouldn't be so caught up on
who's funding who
i would be more focused
on building
real community real mass-based movements
on the ground that actually speak to
people's needs and the conditions they
are living under right now
that's what's needed we spend way too
much time focused on the days of the
white nationalist movement
rather than the tools needed to protect
defend democracy and manage this white
nationalist threat
well that's a good
transition then to several questions
that have also appeared which really are
asking you
to think aloud if you would about
strategies for the left or for
progressive people
as people think about building those
coalitions as people think about
speaking back about um
raising fundamental questions about the
embeddedness of anti-semitism in in
national politics and more
folks are asking uh what gives you
optimism and where you think
people's energies ought to go there's a
question for example about how we name
these movements and how we name these uh
these struggles for justice um with
anti-semitism and many other things in
mind
and others are asking questions for
example about the place of labor unions
and and other at least
sometimes progressive forces so could
you talk a little bit about how you
think about this strategically
thank you
yeah
so strategically
um
i would argue
that uh
the most powerful
uh win we have in our sale
is actually space and time
and uh that almost sounds contradictory
in the urgency of this moment
but what i mean by this is uh we have to
understand
something i think really critically
right
that this is a backlash uh
against uh uh winning right it is the
racial justice movement that is winning
in this country
look
black lives matters
uh the movement in this country uh in
most polling uh that was done
uh previous to 2021 i haven't seen much
polling for 2021
but uh previous to 2021
right black lives matter was pulling
more support right by percentage of
white america
than ever supported martin luther king
jr in his lifetime right
black lives matters was receiving more
support from white america
right than the student non-violent
coordinating committee the the citizens
that took place in in the 1960s as well
now look
we can look at those numbers and and uh
be sad that it's not 80 percent of white
america right but quite frankly we
should be more shocked than in a society
that so socializes people
uh to other by race
that uh such a significant portion of
white america uh would be polling in
support of black lives matter and that
it's greater than it was in the 1960s
that that's an arc
right towards equity and opportunity in
the society
again look i i didn't grow up i i grew
up
in southern california i grew up very
poor i grew up
through mostly junior high school and
in high school right in a hotel right
that my mom paid for the room by by the
week so i'm i'm not a big fan of the 30
minute sitcom right where uh everything
gets tied up so nicely in the very end
that all the answers get questioned you
know all the questions get answered
everything's so fair and happy i don't
know that world right and i don't think
very many people in this country or in
this world
know that world to know that world where
things get tied up so quickly and simply
is is just a world of privilege that is
beyond my understanding where i live
where the most people live in this
country
uh uh look
struggle is a part of advancing humanity
that's what it means and you know what
it's terrible we have to do it and uh we
shouldn't have to do it so hard but but
we really do that's the job before us to
make it easier for the next generation
right those who are yet to be born
right to continue the path towards
opportunity
this means in in my mind
right letting go of this idea that
simply because i demand
a right that it's simply going to be
given to me and uh uh i i think it's
just not how history is unrolled and
it's not how real life
unrolls so look we have to get serious
we have to understand that we have to
continue to advance a vision verbally of
where we want to go
we have to get very pragmatic about
those things that have been built we
have to stop rolling our eyes i remember
in the early parts of the black lives
matters uh movement right it was a great
shirt i actually love this shirt because
i am i'm an old punk rocker and i like i
kind of like sarcasm right and there's a
great shirt that uh said not my mama's
civil rights movement and folks may
remember that
and uh i like that shirt because it
denoted right this was a new generation
that had a new set of of demands and
what was unique about black lives
matters and what is unique
about black lives matters is that they
understand the things they are asking
for aren't women
right uh as as someone told me right
these are basic rights that shouldn't
even have to be asked for right how
should you even have to demand the idea
that black lives matter right uh that
that uh how is that even a controversial
statement
in 2021 and so they were very pragmatic
in understanding
right that there was a very specific
conversation that they were attempting
to generate in the united states and i
think they did so uh uh very
successfully we need more pragmatism
like that uh in the left in the racial
justice movement here's the second thing
we have to admit
right that we really stumbled in this
moment for 30 years we ignored the rise
of this white nationalist movement and
its impact we rolled our eyes at it
right we laughed at it we laughed at
those who warned about it and we need to
ask ourselves how did we make such a
stumble if we can't ask and answer that
question amongst ourselves right
how are we to understand uh and ensure
that we don't make those same mistakes
of moving forward so there needs to be
much more internal dialogue around who
we are as movements and exactly where is
it that we are trying to go and until we
can answer that question
we can't expect the rest of america to
guess it right
of forest but there's a third piece here
i've often said
that the goal of the white nationalist
movement isn't to target uh people of
color
uh or jews yes they do because it's
effective at sending a message right
it's effective at creating the political
theater
that generates the conversation they
want to have in the society
what i try to tell people all the time
is the real target is government right
it's not people of color who are under
attack
it is the government of the united
states
it is the city of charlotte the city of
dc
the city of portland oregon the city of
los angeles california it is actually
government that is under attack
and we have to begin to mobilize in a
way
that demands that government defend
itself and defend american people
and we don't uh uh we don't take that
seriously
it means also entering government
learning how to govern understanding
policy
the boring day-to-day work right of
maintenance
right a a democracy it's not as fun as
marching
it's not as fun as is making signs
right but it is the work that is needed
to be done for the next generation
we have to stop thinking right that we
are the gods right that recreate society
into our liking
that is a fantasy that's not how the
real world works how the real world
works is that we invest our dreams in
the next generation
and we urgently create space for that
next generation and that means
sustaining democracy
and that means taking governance
seriously in this moment
elected board members so you know uh how
many school partners are running
unopposed this year right record number
and then we're surprised right that
these uh faux attacks on black lives
matters
under the uh uh umbrella of critical
race theory are taking place or that uh
educators and principals are being fired
for talking about the holocaust or uh
slavery it's because we are shirking our
duties
right as change makers in our society
we got to get serious if we don't take
ourselves seriously no one's going to
take us
we got to stop performing and start
leading
thank you eric we're going to need to
let you go i i'm aware of that we we do
let me ask you at least one more
question yeah second um
somebody asked a follow-up question to
the question that i addressed and it i
think it's trying to strike at
the question of how um advances in one
area can don't don't don't put to the
side important advances elsewhere and so
the particular question is about how um
in activism surrounding blm over over
the last few years
you know many jewish activists and
supporters um may have felt that they
became very involved in these struggles
and helped to push for justice equity
and into police violence and and more in
the very recent past but at a moment
virtually simultaneously in which
anti-semitic violence and anti-semitism
more generally also appeared in
the united states and and and elsewhere
in the world
may not have felt that black activists
latinx activists and others stood
similarly with them to
to contest anti-semitism um in its
violent and in its quotidian forms
how
how do we do that work of assuring um
that again uh important an important
focus that comes on our radar for very
urgent reasons doesn't in turn sideline
um or or
eliminate from view something like
anti-semitism um as it emerges and
persists
yeah i i would uh quickly i want to
point folks to an essay i i throw my
writings up on on
i think it's a medium because i'm kind
of a diy right
said old punk rocker so i just throw my
writings there i i i just have this
feeling who's gonna who's gonna you know
uh publish uh uh these writings and so i
just throw them up there uh there's one
i wanna direct folks to like if you
google my name and uh
the essay somebody must be blamed
uh anti-semitism the equal opportunity
ideology so someone must be blamed an
air force
this fuller essay will will pop up
but one of the things that i say that i
think is critically important here is
that anti-semitism is emerging right as
an equal opportunity ideology
right uh anti-semitism crosses every
line of race political party right
primary stance on a wide range of issues
like the uh at the time i think i said
like the the corona virus right this
virulent ideology disproportionately
impacts the jewish community but in fact
imperils us all i went on to say that
the jewish community is actually right
to be concerned in this moment of
populist impulses across the ideological
spectrum right from the grievances that
propelled
a b-list reality tv star into the
presidency
right to the cry of justice that brings
songs of people in the streets in
defense of black lives historically
right the populist movements have always
fed on
and turn and in turn fueled attacks on
jewish people right the jewish community
has a historical right to be suspicious
of populism in the same way that the
black community deserves the right to
maintain its suspicion of law
enforcement in this country right these
are historical documented tensions
and understanding i don't think the
jewish community needs to say much more
to us about why it is suspicious and
concerned about uh populism now look
the onus is on non-jews right to make
this right
and uh uh the way we make it right is by
showing up on anti-semitism
right if uh there are law enforcement
that i have to engage in conversation
right law enforcement that individuals
right not the system but individual law
enforcement
who i know have done some thinking on on
race and how it functions in a society
right have a different set of
relationships with me than law
enforcement who i know don't right and
in the same way right if we want the
jewish community to understand we're
serious about anti-semitism it means we
have to start tackling anti-semitism but
i want to say something to the jewish
community and particularly those who are
white presenting
right um
and it's it's simply this
you're exactly right we can both be
the victims
and perpetrators of bigotry at the same
exact time right we have watched uh as a
disproportionate number of black figures
right have come into the line
limelight around controversies around
anti-semitism
if you understand the nature of
anti-semitism and how it functions it's
actually not surprising
right that a disproportionate number of
black and latino uh individuals right
vulnerable marginalized communities uh
tend to express the most virulent forms
of anti-semitism it's actually
anti-semitism by design right the
purpose of anti-semitism one of the
roles in europe right was to create a
buffer in society between the haves and
the have-nots so that when the have-nots
uh got frustrated they were allowed to
take their frustrations out on the
halves right but this jewish buffer they
were allowed to other and and all the
nefarious things that were happening in
the society
onto that jewish community that was the
pogroms right of the 1800s and earlier
uh in europe well that still that same
theory of change still functions here in
the us and it's often why we see it but
i want to say something else right
we also have to acknowledge that even as
we condemn the anti-semitism that
unconscious racial bias right
anti-blackness plays out in these
conversations right it doesn't make us
bad to admit that these different
dynamics are happening at the same time
i can tell you as a person who wrote his
first essay right
on anti-semitism back in like
1992-91
right
that uh black folks who stumble on
anti-semitism
receive a different level of response
right
than non-black folks who make similar
stumbles and i'm thinking right now of
uh um
uh of uh
i'm spacing on his name right now so so
apologies that the nfl player
uh desean jackson
uh uh uh who made some really incredible
uh uh
horrifying anti-semitic statements
uh uh uh uh
on twitter
and uh uh to the press
and uh you know during that same week
madonna said something uh uh offensive
and anti-smack so did uh um chelsea
handler i think it was excuse me if i
got that name uh wrong uh said something
equally atrocious but there was only one
person who received uh uh attention and
that was desean
jackson
that is the unconscious bias that exists
in society now look i'm not saying
desean jackson didn't deserve that
attention
what i'm saying
is that if you're going to give that
attention to black perpetrators of
anti-semitism make sure you're giving
the same equal treatment and heat right
to white perpetrators if we don't do
that right we're creating wedgies but on
the racial justice side if we dabble in
anti-semitic tropes right if we aren't
disciplined and understanding that
anti-semitism is a form of racism and if
we are about racial justice if we are
anti-racist we have to oppose all forms
of racial justice we are also creating
wedges
wedges between two communities
right that have traditionally been the
bedrock of civil rights in this country
since the 1950s
we each have to be more responsible
stop pointing fingers
and understanding that all of us
function in an unconscious biased
society it doesn't make us bad people
what makes us bad people is being too
lazy right to learn what these are so
that we can try to avoid them because
our children deserve that from us
thank you so much eric um
i think we're going to leave it there i
want to thank you for alerting us to
what you called these stumbles over the
last 30 years that of course you've been
working so hard to address
uh across
three decades now and doing so much for
all of us
for helping us to understand better
what's now at stake um the importance of
thinking about anti-semitism
within broader concerns about democracy
in the united states and worldwide and
about anti-racism as a fundamental
concern of all of us
and why in your words uh it's important
to show up in the right ways
when it comes to anti-semitism as a core
concern for all of us
let me just underscore for everyone
who's here that eric's writings are
posted on medium as he mentioned and i'd
encourage folks to read those articles
carefully where i think you'll find
uh even more to think about and answers
to some of the questions we weren't able
to to get to here verbally
let me think in conclusion my colleagues
at yale's center for the study of race
indigenating transnational migration
and also
the yale program for the study of
anti-semitism especially my colleague
maurice samuels eric thank you so much
for your leadership for your presence
here today um and and we'll look to you
in the years to come to continue to be a
leader on these questions and so many
others thank you i look forward thank
you so much